rockets shooting from where watching
your dad's head get lopped off by a jedi
is bound to mess you up but how does the
new ruler of jabba's palace define
himself today
even by the standards of other bounty
hunters and mandalorian armor boba fett
has a special relationship with deadly
gadgets vet's jetpack comes complete
with a missile that can take down entire
ships his armor comes equipped with
special knee rockets he can fire while
walking toward his targets in several
non-canonical stories it's established
that boba fett's signature helmet aside
from looking cool also gives him 360
degree vision while this didn't seem to
help him avoid han solo's blind attack
and return of the jedi this feature may
make a return in vet's new canonical
stories considering how boba fett's
armor makes him a one-man army it's no
wonder that marshall cobb vanth was
reluctant to part with the armor in the
season 2 mandalorian episode the
marshall even among mandalorians boba
fett's tools make him a force to be
reckoned with
the star wars universe is a rough place
where you have to fight dirty but
sometimes boba fett makes fighting dirty
downright filthy initially this was only
hinted at and the empire strikes back
when darth vader singles out that by
telling him that there will be no
disintegrations in the canon comic book
story star wars age of republic jango
fett number one a ten-year-old boba
executes two experienced bounty hunters
when they try to take him hostage
proving he had the ability to be brutal
even at a young age but it's in the
mandalorian season 2 episode the tragedy
that we learn just how merciless boba
fett is with his targets stripped of his
armor boba uses a tuscan raider gaddurfi
stick against a squad of stormtroopers
who probably all wish he would just
disintegrate them fett caves in their
skulls and brutally impales him with his
melee weapon giving them some of the
most painful looking deaths in star wars
history later he recovers his armor and
takes out the remaining stormtroopers
with bombs blaster shots knee rockets
and a very well placed jetpack missile
by the end of this scene everyone knows
that when boba fett has you in his
sights you can forget about running away
you're already dead
star wars characters face adversity all
the time but few of them face it as much
as boba fett whose entire life seems to
be fighting with his back against the
wall while bobo receives training and
guidance from his father jango for the
first few years of his life he
essentially needs to make it on his own
from the age of 10 after he's orphaned
in the battle of geonosis he chooses to
make it in the cutthroat world of bounty
hunting then at the height of his
reputation he falls into the sarlacc pit
in return of the jedi and must keep
himself from being slowly digested over
the next thousand years yet somehow fett
survives all of these impossible odds
adding to the aura of danger and
mystique around him when we see him in
the in-credit scene of the mandalorian
episode the rescue he seemingly acquired
a position of great power as the new
prime boss of tatooine but it's
basically a given that this will require
him to perform even more impossible
feats when the book of boba fett debuts
boba fett may have initially shown up in
the service of the empire but he quickly
establishes that he's really just
following the money and in it for
himself shortly after tracking han solo
to bespin for darth vader and the empire
strikes back tech collects the bounty on
captain solo by turning in his carbonite
frozen form to the tatooine crime lord
jabba the hutt in return of the jedi he
remains in jabba's employ until he falls
in the sarlacc pit and then roams the
galaxy alone eventually forming a
temporary alliance with mandalorian
the remains of the empire as fat clearly
states to den jaren in the mandalorian
season 2 episode the tragedy i give my
allegiance to no one
unlike mandalorians who follow a
specific creed that dictates their
actions boba fett makes his own rules
this might make him unpopular but for
this bounty hunter it's the only way to
live
of course just because boba fett lives
by his own rules doesn't mean he's an
entirely lawless man he may be brutal
but he will honor the terms of any deals
he makes with others sometimes those
deals are formal contracts he makes with
regimes like the empire or powerful men
like darth vader other times they're
verbal agreements he offers to bounty
hunters like din jaren which places him
in the mandalorian's debt until he helps
them save the child known as grogu
either way boba fett shows he will stand
by deals made with his employers and
allies that said once the terms of the
deal are complete or his employers try
to stab him in the back all bets are off
that may have been working for darth
vader in the empire strikes back but he
has no problem killing stormtroopers or
blowing up tie fighters in the
mandalorian once he enters into a new
deal with din jaren he may be a
dangerous mercenary but as long as he's
working for you boba fett will go the
distance
until boba fett acquires a partner in
fenik shand after he saves her following
the events of the mandalorian season 1
episode the gunslinger he usually
travels alone nevertheless this bounty
hunter is far from a man without a past
or a family while he doesn't necessarily
identify as a mandalorian that is proud
of his family line and identifies
strongly as jango fett's son this causes
him to respond with extreme anger if
someone tries to write him off as just
another clone trooper he gets into a
violent brawl with coska reeves after
she and bo katan sneered his clone
origins in the mandalorian episode the
rescue he also takes great pride in
showing denjarin the record of his
family tree stored in his armor which
just provides him with an additional
reason to reclaim his famous suit
if there's one thing that distinguishes
boba fett it's his trademark mandalorian
armor while there are now multiple
mandalorian bounty hunters and warriors
running around the star wars universe
there's just something about that's
battle scarred green and grey armor that
tells people they're in the presence of
a dangerous man with a very personal
connection to his chosen wardrobe i
don't want your armor
i want my armor in recent episodes of
the mandalorian fett has cleaned up the
scratches and blaster marks from his
armor and reestablished the important
reasons for wearing this particular suit
while boba fett clearly has the means to
have a new armored suit built for him he
insists on tracking down his original
armor the suit initially belonged to
jango fett after all and is his
strongest link to his father for someone
who's lost as much as boba fett his
armor truly is irreplaceable check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite bounty hunters are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you